[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut apprécier l'économie on peut
aimer l'économie il ne suffit pas
d'aimer pour bien la décrypter
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on ressent effectivement
une forte augmentation des prix
notamment ce qui est visible c'est
vraiment à la pompe quand on fait le
plein avant bah 60 euros on avait
effectivement de quoi faire 600 700 km
maintenant c'est 90 euros donc il y a
effectivement une réflexion qui s'impose
avant de avant de faire un déplacement
depuis deux mois on a essayé de réduire
deux restos en famille par mois c'est
revenu à 1 parce que oui il faut il faut
bien se servir la ceinture
je pense que l'état de refaire un petit
effort
c'est déjà apprécié ce qu'il faut le
carburant il devrait voir un peu comment
remédier à ça j'ai vu qu'hier il y avait
une augmentation paradoxale ce RSA les
aides de la famille pourquoi ne pas
basculer également sur le panier de la
ménagère avec ce genre
quand on s'aperçoit comme aujourd'hui
que finalement la tendance est à la
baisse du revenu disponible brut moins
0,6% on l'a vu en acquis de tendance à
famed 2022 et on prévoit moins 20% pour
2022 en France quand on voit le revenu
donc diminué quand on voit l'inflation
repartir il semble légitime de se poser
la question de savoir que fait le
gouvernement c'est de sa responsabilité
il est au service de l'intérêt général
dit-on c'est ce que disent certaines
tendances
je dis tendance parce que un
gouvernement n'est jamais complètement
apolitique il y a des préférences
partisanes et qui vont colorer un peu
donner un peu une teneur particulière ou
mesures qu'il prend s'agissant des
gouvernements qui mettent en avant mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde
tout gouvernement à la nécessité de
mettre en avant pour priorité la défense
du pouvoir d'achat et bien la tendance
la tendance est presque de faciliter d'y
répondre et de faire des politiques de
soutien de la demande et donc les
politiques de soutien de la demande sont
des politiques qui vont participer à
utiliser la dépense publique l'État dans
sa générosité utilisent la dépense
publique en n'oubliant parfois que les
financée par les recettes qui sont de
nature essentiellement fiscale en France
et par cette dépense il en attend un
effet bénéfique alors si je ne
j'évoquais un temps où je fais une
parenthèse si j'évoque les auteurs les
auteurs c'est essentiellement John
Ménard Kens qui considérait nécessaire
l'intervention de l'État dans l'économie
l'état relance la machine donne du
pouvoir d'achat et ce pouvoir d'achat va
soutenir l'économie parce que ça va
soutenir la demande qui va s'adresser
aux producteurs et des producteurs vont
produire plus donc auront besoin de plus
de bras le chômage diminue et tout
repart donc c'est une politique dont on
dit qu'elle est conjoncturelle parce
qu'elle ne peut marcher qu'à court terme
le problème avec Ken c'est qu'il est
mort deux fois une première fois de sa
belle-mère mais il est mort aussi parce
qu'un jour on s'est rendu compte que sa
politique ne marchait pas ou ne pouvait
pas marcher à long terme et que de faire
cette politique et de la reproduire à
l'identique sur du long terme c'était
même contre-productif pourquoi parce que
quand vous êtes en période de crise
alors si la crise est légère ça peut
marcher et à court terme et le résultat
est là et ça ça fonctionne par contre si
la crise est de plus en plus forte si la
crise s'avère plus forte que prévu les
ménages vont avoir de plus en plus de
crainte vis-à-vis de l'avenir et cette
manne qui leur tombe du ciel pas du ciel
mais finalement du budget de l'État ils
vont l'utiliser non pas pour consommer
plus mais pour épargner plus et Ken
avait raison de dire que l'économie
c'est un circuit il avait une vision
hydraulique de l'économie et pour lui
l'épargne c'était un résidu les peintres
c'était une fuite dans le circuit et
tout ce qui part en épargne n'est pas
retravaillé
recycler dans l'économie donc on
comprend bien que cette dépense
supplémentaire que donne l'état à
destination des ménages si les ménages
l'épargne il la retire du circuit et ça
ne profite à personne en tout cas pas
immédiatement et donc les mesures de ce
type à court terme quand les ménages ont
des craintes pour l'avenir et bien ils
ont tendance à épargner plus et ça rend
pas efficace disons inefficace à moyen
terme ces politiques économiques et ça
va avoir des conséquences sur l'avenir
parce que ça plombe encore plus la
situation budgétaire si le déficit
existait avant et bien il sera encore
plus élevé c'est pourquoi d'autres
économistes des tendances plus libérales
dénoncent cette intervention je dirais
même cette ingérence de l'État ce qu'ils
peuvent appeler eux c'est ingérence de
l'État dans l'économie au motif que elle
ajoute de la crise d'anatrise vous ne
comprenez bien l'État dépense plus il
est déjà lourdement endetté avec un
budget lourdement déficitaire et non
seulement il dépense plus mais
au final ça s'avère inefficace et c'est
double peine pour les individus parce
que non seulement ils ne sont pas
protégés de l'inflation l'inflation
n'est pas corrigée et de surcroît eux ou
leurs enfants auront à payer un jour le
prix la facture il n'y a pas d'argent
magique contrairement à ce qu'on a voulu
nous faire croire intense c'est pas
parce que c'est l'État qui dépense c'est
pas parce que c'est l'État qui payent
que ça n'a pas de coût le coup il faut
bien l'assumer et donc un jour
l'État devra rembourser devra équilibrer
le budget soit il augmentera les impôts
s'il le peut soit ils sont détruit
encore un peu plus et ce sont les impôts
futurs c'est rien ne change toutes
choses étant égal par ailleurs ce sont
les impôts des générations futures qui
seront concernés juste un mot pour vous
convaincre alors si je vous dis 2900
milliards d'euros de dettes publiques et
me dire je n'arrive même pas à imaginer
ce que ça représente moi non plus par
contre si je vous dis cette bête par
français c'est 45000 euros par an par
français là on voit ce que ça représente
parce que là là on c'est quand même plus
je dirais plus réaliste en tout cas pour
le français moyen veut dire quelque
chose et bien l'état on est là 45000
euros il y a 45000 euros de dettes sur
chaque la tête de chaque Français
simplement ce qu'on peut constater c'est
qu'on va avoir ce que l'on appelle des
déficits jumeaux des Twin déficits des
difficiles jumeaux ou déficit budgétaire
s'ajoutera un déficit de la balance
commerciale et tout ceci dans un univers
inflationniste et s'ajoute à cela le
constat c'est que l'État ne décrète pas
il peut décréter des mesures il ne
décrète jamais un résultat concernant
cet environnement inflationniste après
avoir évoqué la responsabilité assez
évidente de l'état du gouvernement qui
est censé protéger l'intérêt général se
pose la question de savoir si les
entreprises n'auraient pas par certaines
par certains aspects nécessité de
prendre leur part à cette lutte contre
l'inflation c'est ce que disent en tout
cas les syndicats qui leur opposent des
revendications salariales des
rattrapages salariales des rattrapages
salariaux de l'inflation c'est la
pression conjoncture c'est aussi la
pression du gouvernement qui parfois
demande aux entreprises de faire un
effort à la grande distribution
d'arrêter un peu ce bras de fer avec les
producteurs donc dans ce contexte
qu'est-ce que l'on peut dire est-ce que
il est légitime de demander aux
entreprises de prendre leur charge de de
participer à corriger les effets de
l'inflation sur l'économie d'emblée je
vous dirais non au sens où on est dans
une économie capitaliste développée où
les entreprises dans le secteur privé en
tout cas on l'a l'autonomie de leur
décision pourquoi elles ont l'autonomie
de leur décision et bien parce que
finalement
leur activité c'est à elle de
l'entretenir elles doivent veiller à la
bonne santé de leur entreprise la bonne
santé d'activité parce que elle se
doivent d'avoir une activité pérenne
l'entreprise doit être pérenne dans un
univers concurrentiel on ne peut pas
accepter d'avoir des difficultés et on
ne peut pas accepter finalement une
activité une gestion approximative quand
l'inflation perturbe la profitabilité
des entreprises et bien ne peuvent aller
vers une modération salariale parce que
la générosité aujourd'hui
entacherait les chances de pérennité de
l'entreprise de demain donc on pourrait
être généreux aujourd'hui mais c'est
pour que l'entreprise mette la clé sous
la porte de main ça n'a aucun intérêt ni
pour l'entreprise ni pour une salarié ni
pour l'économie tout ce que l'on vient
de dire ici et valable sauf dans un cas
dans le cas de ce qu'on appelle les
positions dominantes pour les
entreprises position dominante on vous
dira finalement l'entreprise elle est
pourcemaker elle fait ses prix alors que
en concurrence l'entreprise elle prend
le prix du marché comme on l'a dit
d'emblée elle prend le prix qui rend
toutes les demandes et les offres
compatibles
pour faire simple qu'est-ce qu'une
entreprise qui domine un marché et bien
c'est une entreprise qui est un peu
comme un monopole on peut avoir un
monopole de situations c'est par exemple
je ne citerai pas de marque mais c'est
grand couturiers le domaine du luxe ou
certains ont annoncé que aucun besoin de
compenser
de baisser les marges pour compenser les
hausses de prix prenez besoin de le
faire puisque le client est une
clientèle captive la hausse des volumes
est parallèle à la hausse des prix il y
a une hausse de volume on vend toujours
plus en dépit du fait qu'il y a une
véritable inflation peut-être même plus
forte encore que l'inflation courante
dans ce domaine mais pour les autres
domaines toutes les activités que ce
soit l'agroalimentaire ou que ce soit le
textile ou les consommateurs sont très
sensibles au prix ou encore ou les coûts
de production sont très élevés ou les
compagnies aériennes ou le kérosène
comptent pour 20% des coûts de
production et bien là il n'est pas
possible de ne pas répercuter dans les
prix les hausses de coûts pour conclure
pour élargir nos perspectives
pour réciter cette adage ce proverbe que
tout le monde connaît l'argent ne fait
pas le bonheur l'argent ne fait pas le
bonheur c'est pourquoi parfois on est
allé voir au-delà on a des indicateurs
en France des indicateurs de bien-être
mais le bien-être vu par les économistes
c'est finalement un annoncement de
valeur ajoutée donc le bien-être c'est
le PIB ce qu'on appelle le PIB dont on
mesure le l'évolution entre deux
périodes et puis on vous dit voilà ça
c'est la croissance la croissance elle
est faite de comparaison de valeur
ajoutée la production de certains moins
la production précédente donc la
production moi des consommations
intermédiaires égales la valeur ajoutée
la somme des valeurs ajoutées c'est le
produit intérieur brut et ça c'est le
bien-être vous allez me dire c'est
complètement abscon cherchons autre
chose certains l'ont fait le roi du
bouton en 1972 un petit royaume où
finalement son peuple était dans un état
de confort très minimum très très minime
un désintérêt pour la chose matérielle
c'est sujet se disait néanmoins à forte
majorité très heureux et donc l'idée est
venue à l'OCDE en 2011 mais un peu avant
à des économistes qui ont été dans une
commission
décidée par Nicolas Sarkozy
Joseph Stiglitz et un artiste ont créé
une commission pour mesurer et pour
créer un indicateur de bonheur intérieur
brut simplement pour mesurer la qualité
de la vie donc il y a plusieurs éléments
qui vont composer ce bonheur intérieur
brut alors l'argent ne fait pas le
bonheur Boris Vian rajoutait aussi
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur de ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas et forcé de constater
que nos environnements nos économies
développées nous imposent aujourd'hui et
nous oblige et nous ne peut faire
abstraction ni de l'un ni de l'autre ni
de l'argent ni du bonheur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]